YouTube has become a reality TV show
everybody from Tanika to fouseytube
to the fight between ksi and Logan Paul
and Jake Paul and Daisy I wasn't even
gonna watch it I didn't even care what I
heard about it but then the mean the
beautiful the beautiful means wherever
there is memes I will be there and the
last press conference was a beautiful
thing Walmart last conference was in LA
this one took place in UK if you ask me
the pol brothers won the first press
scrum conference they just went full
meme case I and Agee they just weren't
ready for it you can tell so now this
one takes place in UK and no one likes
the polls in UK hey dumbass you say
anything else
[Applause]
don't say anything else like Walmart you
guys just keep saying the same thing
whoa their press conference started off
half of it is completely normal because
because it's not youtubers involved it's
actual boxers used to be a boxer yeah we
own this charity crew briefing - all no
one cares by Bob right charity this
charity right come on
yeah then they need to work [ __ ] yeah
boo if daddy's a [ __ ] they felt I can't
I mean the audience must feel dead
destroyed right now
I can't believe they fell for that
oldest trick in the book well play Jake
thought you guys are a desease team yeah
did show and throw and happily yeah
basically people kept throwing things on
stage and me the ref gets so done
respect don't be throwing anything yeah
don't be throwing nothing all right
spoilers people are gonna keep throwing
stuff outside
GPU can you believe this who just throws
G fuel all right on his opponent it's
dead G and then out comes day G and he
finally has a crowd that cheers for him
[Music]
[Applause]
look at the pitch sings hey sweaty stage
piece where Logan Paul look at the pitch
days go be throwing anything yeah don't
be throwing nothing all right cuz it's
an easier fight it's not true
[Music]
can we stop soon
because everyone's gonna go home mix
boxing gym home of zero world champions
zero so Jim thanks bye your gym is bad
[Music]
you're Jimmy's trash to Vic's boxing gym
we trained edgy and that's it that's
right that's right that's how it is
oh my god the comebacks are so dumb and
so bad
here's what you say you don't say yeah
that's it you say yeah they only need to
train the number one or yeah I don't
even need training to break your spleen
right now but then they get into the
real stuff the really important that the
comical observations like what are you
wearing
he's still dressed like do you think
he's deliberately just for this fight
do you think Jake Paul is putting
minimum Chinese try on the secondary
condom do you think that Jake is
deliberately put in bare minimum videos
up to make it look like he's not
training so he's got excuses or just
like he's trying to hide it from here's
the question do you think Jake is
putting our bare minimum videos should
hide that he's actually training what is
the answer to the question this would be
to fight better than he can dress you
dress man no you dress bad uh-huh uh-huh
no you dress behead whose period you're
wearing red too touchy is clearly
smaller than you you're still wearing
heels there's zero percent chance that
there's zero percent chance at that you
went to the ref checks if he's actually
wearing high heels like those are high
heels actually no turtle
don't throw anything come on leave that
leave this honestly I think Jake Paul
won that one because he actually
delivered insults and despite being fish
out of water it's old AG's fancier it's
okay sighs fans he handled himself well
I thought they D didn't really say
anything but then when it looked like it
was all over
Daisy delivers the fattest line the most
devastated line held the century I have
never heard an insult so efficient that
he completely switched the whole thing
around and did you want it the other
states suck you're gonna pay the state
for the title
suck your dad's what is this is so dumb
what they installed no more throwing
seriously because the whole thing will
stop straightaway
[Music]
next up Logan comes out and he looks
like he had the worst his life I
honestly am a bit concerned about him
[Applause]
what is up with him look at him
and then out comes KSA oh snap he did
not he worried the wig oh my god that
woman won't work you boy what is he
doing he look like he's about to cry
hasn't England already suffered enough
we lost a Croatian in the semi-final we
had Trump come over last week now we got
you this week how you feeling bro
he doesn't look like he's feeling well
you're literally in a room with a
thousand people I just despise you
Jesus how are you gonna train with
audition for Baywatch get the part and
still not end up in the final movie
my soul ended up in the final movie
where were you oh yeah
deleted seeds oh let's the end of this
is beautiful because he just stops going
after Paul Logan and he goes after her
his parents instead you know tight your
disgusting man
you said you beat me in the fight you
said you beat me in the fight with one
hand right you wouldn't do spit you're
an old man but I'm sure I'm sure you
wouldn't mind loss in one run before the
little girl she liked kissing oh oh oh
my god he looks like he's trying to be
20 you sick deadbeat broad-headed
oh my god are you gonna make not one but
two dumbass children your mom Jesus this
thing is so dumb I can't believe hey hey
I would sit here and answer your
questions or I feel like ksi address
everything Oh Adrian I'm out I'll see
you August 25th damn I can't believe
Bale
[Applause]
[Music]
YouTube is strange please right now but
it's entertaining at the very least at
least we have that at least it's not
boring no good Paul has disconnected
from the lobby man he didn't even try it
did it Jesus Christ next up is to fight
I don't know why I'm so invested at this
point this is so dumb I hate our on my
message it's like when you watch the
trash TV and you're like why am I
watching this no I don't want just go
away they G seemed like no one was
rooting for him like all his friends
keemstar they're all like I don't think
he can beat Jake Jake is a lot bigger
but I felt bad for day G I was like damn
especially after the LA conference I'm
like wow no one's rooting for him he
changed trainer but he's also such an
idiot
he's also so dumb like it's very
conflicting emotions here I want a route
for day G but he's just too much of a
[ __ ] but then again you have Jake who's
a double moral I think the reason why
this isn't matches so agency because I
don't care who wins it's the same thing
but what I hope happens is that Jake
wins over day G because to be honest I
don't care who did you fights next right
I would rather see Jake challenge
someone else next that would actually be
interesting I think ksi is gonna beat
Logan Paul and I also hope that's gonna
happen not necessarily because I hope ki
is gonna win but Logan Paul he probably
had the worst year of his life I do feel
a little bad for him he never really
recovered after the whole Japanese
incident and yes he's a [ __ ] yes
everyone knows now that he's a [ __ ] but
I feel like there are definitely worse
people on YouTube and then case I can go
on and challenge more people as well so
you have one winner from each team
that's what I hope at least I don't know
why I care I don't care by the way I
trust me I don't care like you can go
either way I don't care alright why am i
promoting this for free they're just
gonna claim the video like last one
[Music]